este diagrama muestra todos los posibles
resultados para cuál de las siguientes
situaciones empecemos viendo esto
nombraron cada columna elfo hobbit
humano y nombraron cada fila magia
espada escudo resortera y sombrilla y
tenemos 15 posibles soluciones 5 x 3 y
existen unas cuantas maneras de hacerlo
podríamos decir voy a crear un personaje
en este que parece un juego de fantasía
el primero voy a escoger uno de cinco
posibles accesorios o herramientas o
armas y luego voy a escoger el tipo de
personaje entonces hay cinco
posibilidades aquí y para cualquiera que
escoja habrán tres posibilidades habrá
un total de cinco por tres resultados
diferentes
puedo ser un hobbit con una resortera o
puedo ser un humano con una sombrilla
puede ser un elfo con una sombrilla
puede ser un elfo con magia todos estos
son posibles resultados también puedo
hacerlo de la otra manera
primero escojo el tipo de personaje un
elfo un hobbit o un humano y entonces
son tres diferentes posibilidades y para
cada una de ellas hay cinco posibles
accesorios que puedo escoger entonces
una vez más 3 por 5 ahora le damos estas
y veamos cuál cuál de estas aplica crear
tres personajes de diferente tipo y
escoger una herramienta al azar para
cada uno entonces aunque asumiéramos que
estos son los únicos tres tipos de
criaturas disponibles elfos hobbit y
humano así que si creas tres personajes
de diferente tipo tendrás un elfo o un
hobbit y un humano y vamos a escoger una
herramienta aleatoriamente para cada uno
entonces cada uno va a tener cinco
posibles herramientas y el número total
de posibilidades será cinco para el
primero por cinco para el segundo por
cinco para el tercero
entonces para esta situación de aquí
asumiendo que estos son los únicos
personajes posibles tendremos un elfo un
hobbit y un humano y 125 posibilidades
esta situación no es la de aquí
crear 15 personajes para un juego y
escoger aleatoriamente cada vez entonces
cada personaje tiene tres posibilidades
si asumimos que estos son los únicos
tres elfo hobbit y humano para el
primero hay tres posibilidades el
segundo tiene tres posibilidades y el
tercero tiene tres posibilidades
entonces el número total de posibles
resultados para 15 personajes
básicamente tendríamos que multiplicar 3
15 veces 3 a la potencia 15
un número muy grande mucho más grande
que 15 entonces esta tampoco aplica
crear un personaje para un juego
escogiendo aleatoriamente entre 5
herramientas y después escogiendo entre
tres tipos diferentes de personajes para
la identidad del personaje bueno esta
suena como lo que describimos al inicio
de este vídeo escojo una de cinco
herramientas y dada la herramienta que
tengo puedo escoger uno de tres
personajes 5 x 3 15 posibilidades
crear un personaje para un juego
escogiendo aleatoriamente entre tres
tipos de criaturas
cierto hay tres posibilidades allí o
tres situaciones después escoger entre
cinco tipos de herramientas tres por
cinco quince posibles resultados
entonces está parece aplicar también